I
self-consciousness which is at first
only the notion of spirit enters on this
path with the characteristic of holding
itself to be as a particular spirit
essential being and its aim therefore is
to give itself as a particular
individual in actual existence and to
enjoy itself as an individual in it
paragraph 358 is very short but there is
a lot actually going on there or at
least that we can unpack by by
implication in what's going on there at
the level of the text so what we've got
here are essentially two different
things that that are connected with each
other self-consciousness helps bubu sign
right and its aim or its goal or its end
as we've seen Hagel's is using vac as
the the key term and Miller is
translating vacuum in a variety of
different ways just read the same term
in with with each of these so self
consciousness has some sort of goal but
the goal is something that is stemming
from what self consciousness is at this
point and what it feels itself to be
lacking and remember what has self
consciousness now come to lack what
would it came apart for it what is self
consciousness missing the ethical
substance that it was participating in
in a happy state originally now it's
it's progressing and it itself is going
to try to provide ethical substance to
itself that's what's going on here in
the background of this passage so he
tells us that self-consciousness as an
individual self consciousness is only
the notion of spirit so far and here's
where we've got to be very careful when
we're thinking about these hey galleon
terms like notion begin cept and spirit
guys because isn't the notion of spirit
exactly what we're shooting for the
entire time isn't the notion spirit
itself working itself out through
history well there's there's that sense
and then remember as I pointed out so
many times
there's the mere notion the undeveloped
or underdetermined notion that is not
yet gone through development but is is
subject to it and it has it as its
potential it's ready to have that done
to it so to say that self-consciousness
is only the notion of spirit means that
it is spirits but it's abstract remember
just a paragraph ago we were talking
about self-consciousness having to go
through a process of experience learning
about the ethical that's what's going to
be happening here so it's more important
though is that self-consciousness holds
itself like he says to be the essential
being is how Miller translated but
essence is just fine to the vases that
which is important that which things
center around self-consciousness the
individual self-consciousness holds
itself to be the essence as here he says
individual spirit ines on their Geist
again Miller is a little bit misleading
and translating this as merely
particular spirit since we've been
talking about the individual this entire
time this is an individual mind or an
individual person let's say if you like
that better because Geist is a little
bit more than just you know our mental
states or something like that as we've
seen in the previous paragraphs it
encompasses our body as well including
you know the heart noggin of the skull
and the brain inside and all these other
things these these are all parts of our
Geist right as our actions as our
relationships now self-consciousness as
he says holds itself as individual
spirit to be the essential thing this is
very important
it's going to be proceeding aware of
their being a society aware of there
being other individual beings aware of
all this sort of stuff but focusing on
itself and its own experiences and its
own development and what it thinks about
itself and what it learns about itself
in the process so this now gets us over
to talking about the aim that's vac the
end the goal what it's desiring Hagel
says that it's actually desiring to
inter related things this also is very
important to one is he says by its own
activity that it gives itself what we
can translate as realization Miller here
has this this low cution actual
existence that's just fine as well
fairview click on making itself veer
click real actual effective something
that does something in the world
fairview click own means this process of
or this state of becoming or having
become real be coming in having become
really those two should be understood
together as rolled into this because the
individual is as spirit not only in the
future but also in the past and the
future and past are bound together in
the present where action happens so
giving it self realization through its
own activity right give itself as a
particular existence and actual
existence and then he says to enjoy
itself in that actual existence or that
reality in that being this is a
transition from essence to reality to
the realization of essence so if the
essence is going to be something like I
am a being
that seeks pleasure and can't get enough
of it which way some beings think of
themselves isn't it not only think of
themselves as in like how they talk to
themselves when they look at themselves
in the mirror or when we see them in a
movie when they're having soliloquies
right but how they actually behave how
they comport themselves other beings are
going to focus on avoidance of pain
other beings are going to focus on
social status other beings are going to
focus on what they think of themselves
and what their projects are right and
Hagel says that in this whole thing they
are not just their they're trying to
enjoy themselves and not just in the
sense of perhaps you know physical
pleasures although that's one of the
modalities that he's going to examine
Zeke xoogan Isom enjoying itself in the
sense of enjoying what it is that its
life is enjoying what it is that its
activity produces enjoying what it is
that it learns about itself and about
life in general by partaking it in
certain things again if we use pleasure
as an example just you know I'll use an
example from from my own life I found
out that Cuban cigars which you know
we're supposed to be really really great
are pretty good but they are not quite
as good as they're made out to be in
part because the non Cuban cigars are
pretty good too then we can get over
here in the states you know you go to a
cigar shop I went up to Montreal one
time and I was you know had the
opportunity now to smoke a Cuban cigar
because you couldn't get them in the
states except illegally but I went to a
cigar shop and SAT there and puffed away
and had my little you know espresso to
go along with it and it was great it
wasn't particularly worth what I paid
for it and I learned something in that
process and you might say oh well you
enjoyed yourself less than didn't you
the less than your expectations well yes
if we want to count
physical pleasure but I also gained so
much more in the experience and I
enjoyed myself in this sense more by by
doing so by finding out for myself there
there are many things that we can talk
about like that so self-consciousness
now is going to be engaged in this
entire process of trying to figure out
who the hell it is and what it actually
is about and what it means for it to be
essential and how that's connected with
the world and the things in the world
including other self consciousnesses
that might be looking at it and talking
with it and judging it and and you know
becoming friends with it or enemies with
it all these sorts of things are rolled
up in this task so again you know that
that's more than the mere words are
saying in this this very short passage
but I think it's important to keep this
in mind as we're now on the very cusp of
moving into these these incredibly
interesting and revealing dialectics
where self-consciousness is trying to
figure out what what really is essential
to it
in holding itself to be a quad being for
self essential being it is the
negativity of the other in its
consciousness therefore it appears is
the positive in contrast to something
which certainly is but which he has for
it the significance of something without
intrinsic being consciousness appears
split into this given actuality at the
end which it realizes by superseding
that actuality an end which in fact it
makes an actuality in place of that
which was given its primary end however
is its immediate abstract being for self
in other words seeing itself as this
particular individual in another or
seeing another self consciousness as
itself the experience of what the truth
of this end is raises self consciousness
to a higher level and from now on it is
itself its own end insofar as it is at
the same time Universal it has the law
directly within it in carrying out this
law of its heart however it learns that
the individual in doing so cannot
preserve himself but rather that the
good can only be accomplished through
the sacrifice of the individual and self
consciousness becomes virtue what virtue
learns from experience can only be this
that its end is already attained in
principle that happiness is found
directly in the action itself and that
action itself is the good the notion of
principle of this entire sphere that is
that thing hood is spirits very being
for self for itself becomes in the
course of this experience a truth for
self consciousness having discovered
this self consciousness the snow's
itself to be reality in the form of an
individuality that directly expresses
itself an individuality which no longer
encounters resistance from an actual
world opposed to it and who is aim and
object are only this expressing of
itself
with paragraph 359 we now end this
introductory section that precedes these
three dialectics that I have written
down here which we're going to do
observe now the individual
self-consciousness working things
through now we can also see these is
just an aside as you might say something
like ideal types or even certain kinds
of ethics if we won't understand ethic
in not a very technical sense as it you
know like the study of ethics but but
ways in which people really do try to to
live things out in the world which is
similar to what Hagel is talking about
here and what we've got here is a really
important transition point I think this
is one of the clearer transitional
paragraphs where we have a good sense of
what would Hagel's about but I also
think this section is particularly clear
as well come by comparison to some of
the other things we've traversed so far
so he says in holding itself to be qua
being for self you know the being that
can actually reflect upon itself that
grasps itself not only in its own
thought or its own words but in
regarding its own action and its own
commitments in holding itself to be quad
being for self essential being or the
essential the vases Hagel says that
self-consciousness is also the which is
going to call the negativity of the
other the other is going to play a
fundamental role in the rest of this
entire section and really throughout the
entire phenomenology right we know that
self-consciousness from the
self-consciousness section is only
self-consciousness because it exists in
relation to other self consciousnesses
that it's not ever entirely what it is
as if it's like a self-conscious
over here and then the other is just
over there and they encounter each other
and now they relate to know they're
already related to begin with and this
also goes for ethical substance as well
so there's more than one other you might
say there's the Big O other and then
there's the little ooo there that starts
to sound a little bit like lecom but
this is where Lacan got this sort of
stuff from right the Big O other would
be that of the society or you know the
the mores and the little Oh other would
be an actual other who I encounter but
let's go on he says in its consciousness
therefore it appears as the positive it
doesn't feel itself to be lacking as in
its essence lacking the for itself in
this case being for itself means
asserting itself and so he says in
contrast is something which certainly is
something which has being but which has
four at the significance of something
without intrinsic being and here the
German is you know Nick on Ziggs I'm
right it doesn't have its own stability
you might say so he goes on and he says
consciousness appears split split into
two things now I just remarked a second
ago that consciousness you know is in
relation to its other and you could read
that in here implicitly but you don't
necessarily need to do that and I think
it could actually be a little bit
counter productive to do that at this
point because what we've got
consciousness splitting itself into as
these two things that are necessarily
connected with each other and they both
are for consciousness there are ways in
which consciousness is for itself that
you might say these are the poles by
which consciousness locates itself in
the world that it inhabit
and is acting upon trying to consume in
certain ways or to change their by
finding itself in the world so that's
not what hegel actually says here I
think that's what you have to read in
there implicitly so he says it's self
consciousness finds itself split into
two things a given actuality and the end
again Zach right we see that once again
let me remind you Miller in this entire
passage is translating it's vac in
multiple ways as end as goal and in some
cases even as other things all right so
he goes on and he says it appears split
into this given actuality a for goophone
in de vere click kite right given you
know for go Fernanda discovered in
advance so it yes it is given the
emphasis in the German is less on it
being given and more on consciousness
actually having it there to find but I
think those are rather core relative
lyrically kite actuality works just just
fine so he says the given actuality and
the end the end is realized the end is
made here lake right the end is realized
through the super session of self which
is a translation of 00 cable over Haven
elf hable right and he says that here we
go superseding that actuality know maybe
it is of Haven there and the end an end
which in fact it makes an actuality a
new actuality in place of the original
actuality that it was seeking out that
sounds very abstract what are we talking
about there let's pick some things that
we can relate to as examples let's take
one that we're involved with right now
we're reading Hangul
we have some sort of given actuality in
front of us this book go find it on the
shelf Hegel's phenomenology of spirit I
always wanted to read that book I've
heard it's really good pick it up it's
our reading thread imagine being at the
bookstore and paging through this what
the hell is this I don't understand
anything about what's going on and then
we work we work we work we work we work
right and gradually oh yeah no no I
start to see what is happening the the
goal understanding becomes an actuality
in its own case here's where it gets
really interesting whenever a goal is
realized it's never realized precisely
as the ideal that it was when it was
just a goal when it was what was driving
moving from the actuality what we know
because we're experiencing it to this
whatever it's going to be out there that
we're desiring it ends up being in
something else sometimes quite different
than what we originally intended it to
be so he says its primary end who's
talking about self consciousness again
its primary end is its immediate
abstract being for self now here's where
Hagel is actually in a certain sense
talking about the dialectic of pleasure
and necessity which is the first one
that we're going to look at which runs
from paragraphs 362 paragraph 366 not
not a lot there right just seven
paragraphs but we'll get through that
fairly quickly and then we can do that
because that is fairly abstract turns
out pleasure pleasure is sort of like
sent certainty it seems to be the most
you know concrete the most rich thing
that we could look at but it actually
turns out from a dialectical perspective
to be rather abstract and impoverished
makes more sense when it's located in
terms of something else now he says here
in other words seeing itself as this
particular individual in another or
seeing another self consciousness as
itself there we have the intro the
reintroduction of the other and the the
relation the dialectical relationship
with the other that's going to come into
play with pleasure and necessity as
we're going to see that's going to come
into play and stay in play through all
of this one way of thinking about that
is as you're progressing through
pleasure and necessity or law of the
heart and frenzy of self-conceit or any
any of these sorts of things we are
realizing effectively that other people
are coming along with us that other
people are seeing us that we are seeing
ourselves through the eyes of other
people that we're not doing it totally
independently on our own which is really
quite quite a realization some some
people don't have that and they stay
stuck in those cycles all right so he
goes on and he says the experience of
what the the truth of this end is raises
self consciousness to a higher level
right move from this level to this level
from now on it is its own end insofar as
it is at the same time universal and has
the law directly in it this is going to
be this discussion of the law of the
heart which is also going to land us
into the frenzy of self-conceit in both
of these cases like pleasure and
necessity pleasure doesn't turn out to
be what we took it to be and it doesn't
even turn out to be the kind of end that
we thought instead necessity turns out
to be the true meaning of pleasure the
frenzy of self-conceit turns out to be
the true meaning of the law of the heart
Vega disappointment there for those who
are you know into the law of the heart
and we're going to find out that the way
of the world turns out to be the true
meaning
a virtue turns out to be the real
actuality that was lying behind that end
but anyway going back to this so the law
of the heart says in carrying out this
law of a heart its heart it learns that
the individual cannot preserve himself
what can get you out of the frenzy of
self-conceit virtue which requires that
the individual remember we're talking
about the individual self consciousness
as being essential it can only remain
essential it once it reaches that stage
by finding something as we say bigger
than itself that it can perhaps connect
with or if need be sacrifice itself two
or four so he says the good can only be
accomplished through the sacrifice of
the individual and self-consciousness
thus becomes virtue and then he says
what virtue learns from experience can
only be this that its end is already
attained in principle that happiness is
found directly in the action itself and
that action itself is the good so this
is part of what we have to look forward
to that's a much longer section by the
way that one runs from 381 to 393 so
that's that's you know a good size
section and that's going to be very very
interesting stuff I promise you know
looking ahead he goes on and he says the
notion or principle of this entire
sphere that is a thing who diz spirits
very being for itself thing hood is
spirits very being for itself spirit has
to make itself actual describable
objectify abul be able to examine itself
as it were from the outside through the
eyes of another not merely the the
feeling of oneself so he says this
notion or principle becomes in the
course of this experience a truth
for self-consciousness
self-consciousness comes to understand
itself better by going through these
dialectics and we ourselves are going to
understand ourselves better and other
people better and human history better
and human nature by ourselves following
along through these these dialectics as
Hagel is turning them out for us so he
says having discovered this
self-consciousness knows itself to be
reality in the form of an individuality
that directly expresses itself that
focuses on itself that says I am going
to be the essential thing I'm going to
see where that takes me so he says an
individuality which no longer encounters
resistance from an actual world opposed
to it and whose aim and object are only
this expressing of itself that sounds a
little solipsistic and we don't want to
end with thinking oh well it's just you
know kind of a narcissism with
dialectical overtones or anything like
that no it's not that it doesn't
encounter any resistance from the world
it will in fact encounter resistance
from the world in the course of this
experience but it's also going to find
that that resistance comes from its very
own self and the other who is within it
and that's a very important lesson so
now we have some really interesting I
would go so far as to say fascinating
dialectics to work our way through we're
finished with this introductory section
we have a clear idea where we're going
and why we're going that way and we have
a lot to look forward to